[Musique]
tout
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va les filles non tu
m'embrasses pas l'embarras comment ça
s'est passé michael jackson a raconté
michael jackson raconte michael jackson
raconte moi michael jackson ouais c'est
ce qui s'est passé j'étais cours entre
ouais parce qu'on a dit alors tu as payé
ta place jacques les billets avec les
billets vip tu es allé dans l'entrée de
tout le monde c'est ça hein mais s'était
fait jeter
ouais n'était pas arrivé en fumée le mac
je vais te dire comment ça va qu'est ce
que tu as toi quelqu'un t'a fait
chihuahua qui pourquoi ça va aulas l'âge
est là d'un coup j'ai l'impression
d'être le gros relous et tout grave qui
veut mater tout aussi tu fais la gueule
bon d'accord ok je me casse mais les
acteurs qui fait parlement italien dis
moi un truc en italien je crois que
c'est comme la mieux je suis bien sûr
c'est un plaisir
bon c ou stéphane alors là ça se passe
bien la super bien avec un bon alésien
reuse l'annoncent les news bon allez
c'est les news la salle uc freenews le
premier jt libre le premier gîte est
entièrement réalisée sans oreillettes
sans oreillettes dans les oreilles mais
aussi sans oreillettes dans la tête
et comme nous sommes un véritable jt
libre nous ne vous parlerons pas des
grands titres qui font la une des autres
journaux nous ne vous parlerons pas
ainsi des derniers sondages qui se
contredisent qui donnent la gauche
gagnante le matin et la droite gagnante
le soir au jt de tf1 car c'est celle au
jt de tf1
la droite est toujours gagnante en
internationale nous ne vous parlerons
pas non plus de la soi-disant rencontre
historique entre mobutu et kabila au
large des côtes sud africaines pour
sceller l'avenir
usa here parce que pendant que les
dictateurs palabres les massacres des
réfugiés rwandais continue on vous aura
prévenus pour nous mobutu kabila c'est
la même chose deux tyrans sanguinaires
l'un à une toque en léopard l'autre et
un léopard en toc
regardez bien ces images ce sont celles
du site internet du fbi la super police
américaine si ces visages vous disent
quelque chose votre témoignage intéresse
la super police américaine voici offerts
à la vindicte populaire le top ten des
criminels les plus recherchés par le fbi
haye
les portraits des malfaiteurs sont
remises à jour régulièrement et diffusée
sur le réseau des réseaux
vous saurez tout sur leur sinistre
palmarès comme on dit dans les rubriques
de faits divers
et si vous avez une âme de chasseurs de
primes que la délation ne vous fait pas
peur ouvrez l'oeil car les récompenses
s'élèvent parfois plusieurs millions de
francs heureusement qu'internet ce n'est
pas seulement cela c'était freenews le
premier jt libres 3 minutes d'infos
nécessaire ciao
[Applaudissements]
la fin du nord
les cours de la bourse en direct
l'évolution des marchés en temps réel
l'anticipation des indices monétaire au
jour le jour
le top des meilleurs golden boy minute
après minute la tendance des taux
notionnels toutes les secondes c'est
très sympa mais c'est pas sûr dit wang
[Musique]
détendez vous écoutez ma voix répéter un
traitement absorbé des substances pour
ce fait du shopping mur
procurez vous des biens consommés des
choses
acheter des produits pour moi acheter
des trucs dans les magasins j'aime bien
regarder les publicités à 3 vous vous
réveillerez et vous n'aurez aucun
souvenir de ce que vous venez de vivre
un deux trois bonsoir je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée à l écoute des
programmes de free one sur france 2
également dimanche à 10h30 le jour du
seigneur
si vous avez loupé le début un prêtre à
la robe aux couleurs chatoyantes
accueille dans son église des fidèles
qui se lèvent s'assoit et chante sur
france 2 à 22h55 d'eric série policière
allemande violent non choquant non vous
allez regarder non 20h45 lundi soir sur
tf1 les yeux d'hélène un feuilleton en
neuf épisodes si vous avez loupé le
début continué et si vous restez avec
nous bien sûr ce que je vous souhaite
aller coûte des programmes de free one
et bien voici à l'énoncé de ce qui vous
attend par mes jeunes collègues les
frimousses
bonsoir surpris one il y a bien sûr
aussi les jeux mais des jeux comme on
n'en voit qu'un pion free world
[Applaudissements]
départ d'alix chevalier le premier jeu
basé sur l'actualité des stars
enfin maman sa femme l'a quitté propos
quand je retournais qu'est ce que c'est
je suis déçu les fusions regardez
regardez un prog votez pour moi je vais
vous
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir vous la dire bonsoir à toutes et
à tous je suis ravi de constater que
vous êtes chaque soir plus nombreux à me
regarder dans mon émission
[Applaudissements]
oui je suis là pour vous oui je suis là
pour vous dire avertir et moi et
quelques-uns de mes amis à l'enfer de
cette soirée l'événement dont vous
parlerai demain dans votre petite vie
alors que moi je serai là encore sur ce
plateau à accomplir mon destin vous ne
connaissez pas vous l'a dit c'est une de
mes amis de tf1
je vais bientôt la rejoindre sur cette
chaîne mèche n'en parlons pas pas un mot
pour l'heure j'accueille tout de suite
mes invités il dirige la compagnie ses
muscles ont fait le tour du monde hélas
son cerveau est resté à quai mesdames
messieurs je veux le mans d'applaudir
sylvester stallone
[Applaudissements]
des poupées banques notamment en
s'impliquant faisant l'amour sur une
balançoire que son mari est installé
dans le salon de leur villa de beverly
hills
mesdames messieurs
là en dessous de 10 sur le tour elle est
délicieuse
voilà l'équipe fréquenter les marchés
me fait rire que lui quelques-uns de ses
potes et sa maman il s'est marié avec
une chanteuse qui pourrait être sa maman
est aussi tout ça peut payer moins
d'impôts il a le nez tellement poudre
est que lorsqu on lui tape dans le dos
et pompes deviennent toutes blanches les
dames messieurs d'un tendon
hier assis toi que la touche qui dément
pas ophélie tu te souviens lorsque tu as
débuté tu as fait courir le bruit pour
recueillir un petit peu de presse
je te tue a fait croire que tu avais une
relation et qu'un chanteur américain
d'un banc pris le love symbol n'importe
quoi bladi moi aussi je peux faire la
même chose a alors fait très tapis ou
pas oui beaucoup dans le noir c'est faux
maintenant on fait les ce n'est pas vrai
ce n'est pas ma chérie alors je
m'approche de toi et tu as les arguments
c'est vrai ou pas mais lorsque chen avec
toi c'est que quand tu fais quelque
chose tu le fais à fond
oui elle le fait à fond se souvient tuba
malades de ton enterrement de vie de
jeune fille c'est vrai j'avais vu que tu
ne peux pas te souvenir
et pourtant rappelle toi ce garçon avec
qui tu as passé ta dernière nuit de
célibataire n'était ce pas un ami de ton
mari non et bien c'est eh bien si
[Applaudissements]
oui pamela oui c'était le meilleur ami
de son mari c'était le témoin alors je
ne savais pas que 2000 et est partageur
je pense qu'il y avait moyen de moyenner
si éventuellement je vais parler à
quelqu'un oui bon je t'adore
l'émission maintenant touche à sa fin
vous l'a dit ne soyez pas inquiet je
serai là demain bien sûr fidèle au poste
toujours plus fort toujours plus grand
que vous retrouver pour un pic oui
mesdames messieurs à demain je vous
embrasse va être chaud bonjour je
m'appelle jennifer je suis standardiste
pour free quiz alors à peine moins vite
et vient gagner des centaines de
milliers de cadeaux
[Musique]
oui il ya quelqu'un [ __ ] mais
qu'est-ce qu'il fait noir ici c'est pas
possible
[Musique]
bonsoir toujours je souhaite toujours
une excellente soirée toujours à
l'écouté des programmes de free world
à signaler également mercredi pas
brusquer mois mercredi à signaler
également sur france 3 la cuisine des
mousquetaires a été nous proposera des
daurades deux oranges et citrons verts
choquant oui violent oui érotique non si
vous restez bien sûr avec nous sur guan
ce que je vous souhaite
et bien voici tout de suite le
déroulement de votre soirée par mes
collègues les frimousses non mais
malheureusement maintenant place à la
musique avec lift off le type arabe
n'est plus à présenter
par flore
le résultat
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pas
c'est cela
bonsoir paris qu'on soit mieux ancré new
york signaler les charmes il annonçait
le free to your money
[Applaudissements]
penser que cette flotte vers l'arrêt
voulais que ça bouge ce soir vous voulez
que ça bouge
[Applaudissements]
musique la musique c'est pas toujours
des trucs bien c'est aussi des trucs
quand on les écoute on à la cervelle
pour toi c'est quoi les progrès
attentats temps et tout ce que je dis
pas ce que tu va me remplacer quelqu'un
que tu va me remplacer
tu vas pas remplacé attention y'a un
truc kenaz surtout vous laissez pas
attraper on est là pour vous réveiller
les garçons l'album de julien clerc
demain ce sera au oasis c'est vraiment
menacé par des miettes par bulut pardon
pardon pardon l'émotion et vous aimez le
rock alors qu'abel pas descendre quand
météo quasi permanent c'est pas ma
chance de lancer comme maintenant c'est
le top hat 10 jours défi avec des culs
comme un dessin ses 740 boys
comment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cork
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dagobert même heure même chaîne frais
ouah data
[Applaudissements]
pour moi acheter des trucs dans les
magasins j'aime bien regarder les
publicités à 3 vous vous avez ray et
vous n'aurez aucun souvenir de ce que
vous venez de vivre un deux trois comme
tous les frimousses aubin hockey bonsoir
bonsoir il est l'heure de free access le
magazine du mas de free one way juste
derrière si vous permettez les filles je
ferai une petite émission compagnie de
mes chroniqueurs une mais chroniqueuse
une chouette équipe et nous recevons ce
soir princess erika voilà dans au free
access ibuki envoyer vos images
nous on les passe et ça c'est nouveau du
coup ça mais y'avait pas vidéo gag déjà
rempart c'est la même chose
ok désolé si ni là ils ont été 1
je peux enlever la bonsoir je suis là
pis la clause de conscience intelligente
qui voulait de cette chaîne un petit peu
heureusement que c'est là jusqu'à
présent c'était très jeune ça faisait
beaucoup de bruit et maintenant ça va
devenir très vieux savait très
silencieux un peu comme moi oui
alors on est tous des stars vincent
bénite moi y compris vous avons envoyé
des images vous avez bien fait tant pis
pour vous vous allez regarder tu
commences d'accord je vais vous
présenter une autre question qui peut
régulariser la température et c'est le
monsieur monsieur 0 qui a évoqué un
vendeur au d'après les recherches
scientifiques
on a trouvé que la température optimale
pour la production de spermatozoïdes et
33° 3 dray au dessus ou dessous de la
température du corps et justement c'est
qu'elles sont permet à garder c'est
température en séparant par le système
de séparation parler par deux tampons de
séparation pour les testicules et une
boucle de pénis donc ôter au cap el
islah et c'est réglable donc ça donne
une aération et auto régularisation de
la température et empêche la
transpiration l'irritation de peau et
les sauteurs
je crois qu'il va aller loin tu vas
aller loin mon petit mais très très loin
je vais loin avec toi toujours
voilà c'est aussi ça la télévision
n'oubliez pas ça va je sais bien qu est
ce que t as core team pas de micron
doutons pas ouais il est gentil gentil
tu vois non je suis très triste hélas
juste pas devin thomas avec qui tu as
couché pour faire de la télévision doit
avec thierry ardisson tueur allemand
tu veux participer au triptyque et
copines mais j'aimerais bien j'aimerais
bien mais sur cette chaîne moi toute
façon je suis assez bris mais finalement
on me laisse pas faire ce que je veux
aller à foix j'avais non c'est vrai
c'est le gros plan il est sur moi merci
chacun son tour voilà tu es gentil
voilà tu dégages maintenant voilà à
l'ailé voilà si tu me passes à la
télévision tout aussi turques apprendre
petit caméscope tu fais des images avec
ton de papillons qui clignotent et si
nous les envoie à nous les diffuserons
c'est promis c'est juré c'est free
access
accès libre ola olé je vous traduis je
crois vous le faire en allemand
lituanien en espagnol mais j'ai peur ce
levier de la sent donc finalement je
préfère vous laisser regarder elle à la
régie la donne et discothèques ce qu'il
proposait son micro parce que c'est
comment je baisse le micro qu'il lance
le groupe et ses regards des ménages et
donc juste après que vous ayez regarder
[Musique]
thank you patrick
top line piano enfin lloris bête good
morning today english and to no 10
il est quatre répéteurs woods va donc
juste après ça eh bien ça bonsoir monde
french tv jeune périgourdin de
champigneulles alors puisqu'il va pas
lui parler parce qu'il n'a pas de
champagne moi je vous parlais même en
velin on la nomme amène le même ne
savait pas que je loue venons pleut
aussi vainqueur cheyrou leur disent
enchantés ya it is la classe note bien
sûr consulter tease
voilà voilà voilà à la fois qu'une boîte
à lunch mpi 90 g sieste the do you do il
veut reculer la bouteille de champagne
excusez moi j'étais grossière mais je
traduis mien c'est à dire que j'ai fait
de hautes études de linguistique qui me
permettent de traduire ce genre de jeu
voilà tu as dit pas ce que tu voulais
nous dire en endroit où tu veux
continuer dans une autre langue ce que
tu veux non je vais voter une autre
question parce qu'il est alors voilà la
vie les françaises sac et ce notamment
et ça c'est la chute en principe l'an
couple non non on va continuer parce que
19 minutes après minutes
la fastueuse donc alors je dis je vous
explique donc c'était le monsieur du
chan entre l'agglo cat tic tic tic à la
l'a reconnu il a beaucoup de succès ce
dont je me réjouis aussi j'ai moi même
beaucoup ri ouais mais on va pas tourner
interview me situe à 1 ghz 15 ont
regardé donc ce que je veux dire c'est
que si vous aussi vous faites un petit
film que ça vous pourrez venir nous voir
par contre maïtena je vais faire le chat
2 mais je suis en manque de greffiers
faudrait qu'on fournisse aussi même adam
chat voilà c'est tout pas de problème
qu'est ce que tu fais d'autres dans la
vie j'ai entendu dire que tu faisais de
la radio je cherche du travail sur free
one cherche du travail sur free one une
bonne occasion vas-y mais toi ne me
mettre nue maman
[Applaudissements]
elle est choisie à l'étal en allant là
là
down and on and on and on a
je leur ai kouchner d'essorage en a
maintenant étoiles à toi j'aime
apprendre
cc by sa voilà voilà voilà
il est libre à la con mais c'est bien tu
vois c'est ça quand on fait de la radio
quand vient la télé il ya des caméras on
s'affole twin otter de l'habitat greffe
a pris voilà c'est ça la green room to
zoom zoom zélande octobre la greffe donc
alors free one c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de regarder
oui free access oui l'émission que vous
regardez aussi 9 rue pierre demoures
ouais ça va ça va
notre pierre demoures 75017 paris n'est
pas question qu'on me foute je dis au
revoir je vais prendre mon temps je vous
rappelle donc voilà on sera content et
tout ça que j'ai ma pêche manucure situé
d'esthéticienne tu peux me téléphoner
mon salut hockey
[Musique]
pis moi
salut c'est freenews le premier jt libre
le premier gîte est entièrement réalisée
sans oreillettes sans oreillettes dans
les oreilles mais aussi sans oreillettes
dans la tête
et comme nous sommes un véritable jt
libre nous ne vous parlerons pas des
grands titres qui font la une des autres
journaux re re re bonsoir surpris one
comme sont les vraies chaînes de télé il
ya aussi une émission où l'on présente
des stars et ça s'appelle freestar bien
sûr oui mais c'est là elle est présentée
par yvan le bolloc'h et sa bande sa
bande sa bande pour moi je t'ai des
trucs dans les magasins j'aime bien
regarder les publicités
bonjour je m'appelle samantha je suis
comptable chez free one alors tout à
leur appel tirer ardisson et discute
avec lui en direct
vivent les gens y vivent yvan et oui
mais voilà qu'à et oui les bons vivants
nourrit les mirettes restaurant aller
mais bien beau ce [ __ ] j'en attends je
dégauchis mais pêche là deux minutes
thierry tous les bugs compte at on est
tous et un toit dans le chemin menant
même pas eu de ballon a tenté un quad
core et puis les fruits aussi parce que
c'est bon ça revienne l'attaqué est
franche devant vas-y dépêche toi un chef
seule force je te le fort oui merci je
vais je te le porte yvan un poids bon
[Musique]
j
[Applaudissements]
sa mère
ok
[Applaudissements]
il ya toujours sur un vrai mode la
première télé libre qui fête ce soir son
130e 130e message ans d'existence et
toujours aucune trace de la censure
démonstration rpr quéquette haschisch
thierry ardisson marche contrat régime
non c'est bon on peut continuer vous
êtes donc sur free star je vous souhaite
la bienvenue à gus
je suis encore jouer vos carnets d
adresses mais c'est la dernière fois je
serai pas toujours là yvan marcellus et
j'ai quelqu'un de toc c'est quelqu'un
qui a des choses à dire ces procès série
[Applaudissements]
jamais
rania alors on va tous se tournent pour
l'autre fait si l'on s'interdit tout est
très bien fait pas toujours la main du
tout donc tu as années passées ces
ricains et blackjack son pote de non
plus du goût de son meilleur pote
d'accord très bien on ça tient ou
demeure à s'associer à les séries ça va
bonjour à ses séries 4g saluera le
producteur après je t'aime moi non plus
patricia stéphanie baoule à prendre nous
traversons une phase un peu difficile
puisque ça tu me la prend pas oui est-ce
que je peux finir la phrase ou non voilà
non nous sommes à la recherche
d'investisseurs pour faire que cette
chaîne existe et donc que vous y avez
contribué à mettre en place
voilà on sommes partis chercher des
capitaux auprès de faire de personnes
relativement fortunés si un noir non non
on va voir c'est la surprise en
séparation
on s'adapte et vous avez d'accord mais
c'est des grosses stars des gangsters
oui dérange fortement suivant petite
série nador minuit on est prêts on va
bien sûr tu conduis bon et rien ne se
promet d'ouvrir nos propres capital
devrait bien vite et les adore aller
déjà
il n'y a pas de souci
très mature pas négatif
m
[Applaudissements]
à
alors hein parce que vous avez pris pour
un simple et modeste autographes ces
contrats c'est le contrat à vie à arnold
s'est choisie et george clooney
regardiez sillage la vie ça c'est la
signature grenelle 2 millions de dollars
à 3 après de manière quotidienne
toujours sans déconner attend ça tu me
dis que c'est arnold schwarzenegger mon
cousin ici n'y fait la main maintenant
regarde regard de fou maton et preuves à
l'appui sur l'image non mais je veux
dire qui est jusque là oui parce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il a une signature à
peu un signe il attend suivant c'est une
fois encore gus sait qu'on a un
partenariat avec denis soeur qu'elle son
restaurant en face
ouais je vais de temps en temps pour
essayer de choper la vedette et ouais
choper du gros aussi ouais ouais
en tout cas pas du gros sebastian
dubarbier parmi eux
[Applaudissements]
celui-là
merci bus nino est ce que tu veux boire
quelque chose s'est passé en syrie vous
venez vous tu viens d'où pardon bien un
cornet du restaurant de nice par au
juste là à côté j'ai des farcis niçois
que l'idée de la morue mais avec des
gentils avec moi je pense qu'on va faire
un petit un petit détour par le sujet de
rares solidus hélium des cadeaux mois
propos tenus ce 1
ces coups là ça c'est quoi ça la nuit
comme un pou enn où j'ai rien pour rien
le times habitat et et ça m'a coûté de
faire ça bon ben je le dis je la donne a
black jack et alors là je crois en effet
que j'adore at on fait savoir
d'accord alors n'ont été volées jacques
est ce que tu insinues par la spa parce
qu'il ya ça va tu donc non mais tous
compris son prix moyen est pointu donc
pour amener deux trois trucs à toute
l'équipe
ya pas 36 solutions il faut aller faire
les courses chez forex un bon petit polo
et dan parks a pas l'air trop cher non
plus pour yvan je pense que ça va faire
la farce mois s'essayer au petit
repérage pour ça c'est une arme létale
armes c'est pas une caméra c'est pas
gagné tu m'as tu es mon copain je me
fais un peu ce que c'est bien parce que
c'est de là bas ça c'est d'arz
tu vois c'est bien comme ça
je repasserai plus tard au revoir hop
hop hop l affaire est dans le sac
j'espère que la couleur va te plaire mon
petit yvan voilà beau petit polo à son
pépère voilà à et poubelles est pas
belle la vie
tu prends le portable tu vois tu
t'appelais numéro 9 la boutique
tranquille donc il faudra une petite
paire de lunettes pour gus un pote pas
trop cher j'ai rappelé à japper ouais
c'est pas mal j'ai peut-être d'autres de
tous styles aussi à bahia ma copine
qu'elle a peut-être qu'il va pouvoir me
renseigner
rien n'est rien ce que alors arrive là
c'est rien à trois cas cette voie là
avec moi se moquent les trois cassettes
sais rien
[Musique]
et
oui
cadeau pour moi un petit pet
[Applaudissements]
ça prend quand même un truc c'est de
l'allumer d'être sans plus à la télé ça
sent pas du tout à ça tu peux le voleur
toutes les terres vas-y toi si je peux
savoir d'où tu reviens parce que j'ai
l'impression de hollande où je vis
d'ailleurs ah ouais c'est plus cool non
mais tu es à 500 bornes et il n'y a pas
tous les handicaps qu'on peut avoir ici
d'un seul coup justement ça interdit de
500 bornes la ville où tu peux vraiment
vivre tranquille est-ce que juste une
question du non maghreb et c'est connais
les mecs quoi les fait raison bon
d'accord odéon speed on devine dans ce
pays vous avez vous avez quelque chose
je ne fais plus rien sur la vie on est
remarqué maintenant tous les shows de
florent pagny il porte tout sauf des
tongs regarder pour voir les 2 ra les
dlc pradéens moi je suis jetée rendre je
peins d'andré fois y'a pas de mal non
mais tu savoir parler tant l'excusent
match un tout petit peu l'expérience de
la montagne quand tu des choses fait
deux choses tout en veut à vie même si
elle dit la recherche
certains parce que ta bouffe et du
fromage avant toute façon c'est quoi
votre histoire inspirera peut dévier
mais bolat a sorti et a vu l'heure qu'il
est ma fille
cette fois rempli de la réflexologie
sinon c'est pas une loge est expliquée
non je l'aimais brutale oui c'est ce mec
là qui chantait laissez-moi respirer
[Applaudissements]
si la réflexologie c'est une science qui
est très très en vogue dans les pays
nordiques et qui vient curieusement à
nous c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
déchaussé florent donc la réflexologie
dit la chose suivante c'est que
certaines certains organes de notre
corps genre le foie le coeur les
intestins les organes sexuels et cetera
sont représentés en miniature conduite
emule et tout ça sans représenter ils
ont fait le show miniature sur la voûte
plantaire et sur les orteils en fait nos
travaux de leur dirait un petit peu le
miroir de notre corps c'est la vitrine
de notre oui ça fait tellement de lui il
faudrait que de lui il peut faire du la
victoire attention et tu peux plus jouer
lui voulait du revenu national de
lavande
c'est un instrument seulement de la
vente parce qu'elle crée à la morgue où
on sent moins fort d un petit peu
d'huile tous les marins ont réchauffé
nil et c'est bien parce que j'ai ouï
c'est dégueulasse surface c'est
difficile parce que ces propos de fer et
les orteils donc on n'hésite pas à
effleurer on a pu quand même surtout le
fouet à ce qu'elle a fait une petite
pression en stimulant décontracté
lorsque le pied vient toujours nous et
le pied et on s'amuse à filmer certains
poissons c'est pas digne de la justie
mule confro cellules des sinus paie ton
hypophyse c'est connu ce mouvement
descendant la colonne vertébrale
j'arrive agissements
pars pars ont juste une fille avec
beaucoup de facilité un plaisir pas
dissimuler les testicules qui risque
g.collomb g.collomb danger encore sexy
encore plus on n'a pas de gros finish
doucement je savsis cassés mutilés lui
dans l'abîmé génère lnf un gros souci je
vais travailler à l'instant le plexus
solaire tout le monde sait que lexus
soleil c'est un point à à considérer
doublement vraiment je sens extrêmement
tendue tel point que suspendu d'alex
super tendu elle appelle la salsa
mais on ferme petite musique
et
mais
mouss way salut grâce à lui je bosse à
free one avec le bloc
je voulais m'assurer que tu as la
mission demain et pas de problème quand
même la première fois non mais bon ces
petites émissions des foyers des invités
qu'il faut finir un petit peu donc moi
je me déplace je suis sûr que lui mais
qui viennent je serai là sûr j'ai senti
un peu hésitantes à l'heure et je venais
d'être sûr attendent à ce que je fais
juste ton boulot j'ai dit une fois je
claquais t'énerve pas à se trouver en
violences non mais raf raf est pas
facile comme garçons les costauds en
plus ma chauffer un peu plus il a du pot
bon appétit
je représente le plus gros casque de la
terre un courbet moi c'est comment tu
nous as trouvé la mort et j'ai vu
l'américaine garés tout va on est un peu
fâché tout à l'heure on n'est pas fâché
je te dis je venais à carmaux liquid
accord juste demain quoi tu te rappelles
demain dans l'émission avec yvan tout ça
[Musique]
salut c'est freenews le premier jt libre
le premier gîte est entièrement réalisée
sans oreillettes sans oreillettes dans
les oreilles mais aussi sans oreillettes
dans la tête
et comme nous sommes un véritable jt
libre nous ne vous parlerons pas des
grands titres qui font la une des autres
journaux oui c'est pas grave at en voilà
et vous pousse à vous les voulez des
gens connus je vous emmène et david
regarde ravi d'être là
annie sié n'est que quand on va parler
d'un plan de paix d donc là on prouve
que non c'est moi qui présente françois
revoici frega la première émission gay
de la télé oui y est collé alors laissez
nous c'est moi il faut comme ils veulent
aller
c'est une sorte de tournez manège gay
chanté par gwen et yann qui sont donc
elles ne sont pas ensemble et non que
triquet c'est interdit aux hétéros
interdit à dos voilà on peut rien faire
dans ce cas bon bah me regarde quand
même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
diop bienvenue sur prix gay ce soir un
nouveau rendez vous chaque semaine même
soir mais meurt donc free gay guen c'est
quoi
ebp afrique et c'est l'occasion de
rencontrer l'âme soeur ou qui sait le
coup d'un soir qui entraîne nous
expliquer qu'on va faire un tournez
manège pour gays et lesbiennes eh ouais
et ce soir cinq mecs cinq mecs pour moi
non n'exagérons rien nous avons cinq
nouveaux candidats qui ne se connaissent
pas bien sûr et les deux qui se seront
choisis gagneront un super cadeau
effectivement chaque semaine deux
candidats vont pouvoir partir une
semaine au soleil
oui donc 5 dans les cinq candidats sont
déjà parmi nous les applaudit on
alors avant de les rejoindre
on va vous parler du sujet de la semaine
et ben oui comme à chaque fois on vous a
préparé quelques images qui ont marqué
l'actualité
eva ce week-end c'était l'europride
leeson allez pour vous c'était très très
très chaud il y avait trois cent mille
personnes
on regarde le magnéto
donc on va commencer les premières
questions c est richard qui va poser une
question à fabrice havard fabrice et
écoute bien s'il te plaît parce que
c'est peut-être la chance de ta vie on
écoute via l écoute bien alors la
pression mais plutôt acide côte poppers
vitamine c ça commence très fort non
chewing-gums hollywood
tu es plutôt clitoridienne ou vaginale
je fais pas dans l'attraction foraine
est ce que tu te rases les couilles les
couilles à gagner quelque chose et les
bollocks leipold les pour quoi faire
pour le confort de qualité partenaires
chacun sa merde pourquoi tu rases aussi
loin c'est juste un peu plus haut les we
have asie non je m'en fous de du confort
de mes partenaires
ta tête tu alors messi va falloir vous
fassiez un choix bon alors fabrice pour
toi fabrice ou de philippe richard
fabrice de fabrice philippe
marc en cas de détresse sexuelle
prolonger vous tapez 36,15 beaux mecs
vous vous plongez dans des profondes 10
de wilde vous aller écumer les quais ou
quoi vous aller écumer les quais les
quais de seine
il connaît depuis qu'est ce qui se passe
sur l'aquitaine bah ouais on sait tout
ça j'ai jamais croisés bah moi non plus
on fait quoi non cas de détresse
sexuelle
maintenant je prends ma main je trais
feignants et je prends ma main quel
dosage quel dommage entre huy merci
fabrice à benoît un benoît vous fumez
plutôt des blondes et brunes des cigares
la pipe ou autre chose
tout ce qui passe
[Applaudissements]
j'ai toutes mes chances c'est super on
continue fabrice à richard si
éventuellement ont gagné tous les deux
ce soir ça vous dirait d'organiser des
parties avec les trois autres perdants
et moi je suis encore exemple la partie
la plus il ya un tu te tais tu reste
tranquille si le caméraman oui il est
pas mal de karine et hermine est terminé
maintenant à il faut choisir la alors
richard marcoux benoît hallé ont choisi
marc mars
eh ben c'est ma rue marquis a gagné ont
déjà avec la cagb qu'est ce qu'un jeune
droit justement parler de fête foraine
je pense qu'on n'est pas loin on n'est
pas loin c'est clair bon alors on va on
va enlever la cagoule à matin oui alors
est-ce qu'ils vont se plairait s'ils
vont pas se plaire à wels attention
attention attention
le voici
c'est pas terrible
[Applaudissements]
la bible ou la reid m'a bisou sur la
joue
un joueur a choisi rien là mais c'est
quoi c'est tout blanc rue ils sont
déchaînés ils sont des chaînes pour moi
pour ma famille pour mon look free gay
c'est vraiment très important
et puis c'est vrai que depuis qu'on
regarde cette émission brigitte me donne
beaucoup plus de plaisir
[Musique]
on les voit les préservatifs masculins
placé sur la verge
il s'oppose à la libération des
spermatozoïdes dans le vagin c'est à
dire il crée une barrière mécanique
entre ceux-ci et l'eau
[Musique]
vendredi soir comme tous les vendredis
retrouvez nous arai mois dans will a
aussi bien fait love c'est l'émission
des libertins animée par christophe c
mois free love c'est bien sûr le fameux
strip poker dont chacun connaît le
principe quand on perd on se déshabille
et vous apprenez vite mais c'est
également le multi sexe cette fameuse
tournée en duplex de toutes les boîtes
échangistes de français de la volaille
non pas la hollande draps la navarre ne
ramenaient pas tout à fait quoi une
boîte échangiste
il faut pas tout compliqué zahrach parce
que on va pas s'y retrouver
donc pour résumer free lot c'est tous
les vendredis sur vous vous dites bien
reprenez votre petite pochette en émoi
cette cravate
la comédie a assez duré début d'érection
avec vos conneries donc d'être très très
bien fait vous pouvez les faire de la
télé et comment on dit free l'ogre
hollandais gino qui nous aurait mis à nu
les landaises non non non non c'est très
calme c'est comme moi vous aimez
regarder les programmes sexuel à la
télévision avec des gens données
alors je vous conseille frais love une
émission de strip poker qui est très
bien
[Musique]
re re re bonsoir avant de nous quitter
voici la première émission confessions
de la télé freephone animée par thierry
ardisson et tous les soirs tout le monde
peuple et thiery il répond à chacun je
crois que pour une augmentation ça va
être la seule solution
[Musique]
allô allô allô
ouais ouais c'est qui c'est bernard de
toulouse
ouais voilà j'avais des problèmes avec
ma nana oui il ya des choses qui ne veux
pas me faire ah ça c'est intéressant
vasic watts détails
ouais elle pas muté dans les idées on
reprend un mec alors change pour un mec
que mathieu le coupable
bah ouais si tu aimes te faire sucer il
vaut mieux avoir des mains car il adore
ça ouais mais n'offrent pas tant le
talent pour toi mais j'en fais pas mais
si cette tente il faut y aller tu crois
bon alors il faut le tapis un battant il
n'y a qu'eux qui savent faire ça comme
il faut avantage et un aller j'avais
payé
bah ya longtemps j'ai étudié alors c'est
pas une maladie un loges c'est bien elle
a des gouttes ta gonzesse way dire là un
casque
olala ça fait combien de temps que tu
avec elle disons six mois et tu t'es pas
fait ceci depuis six mois ouais bah t'es
vraiment loin des cons j'aime bien moi
je resterai fois ci moins se faire sucer
mon garçon a tout essayé
ils refusent tout le reste en même temps
je suis sûr c'est que yahoo
et elle l'a eu pour charger de coin que
ouais mais l'hiver la viola servir
battant way s'ouvre est ok c'est à dire
que si elle te fait
après je peux tout l'hiver tu peux tout
lui faire ouais abbas attend ça se
discute alors met d'accord
enfin est-ce que l accepte tout tout
tout tout tout ouais bon alors c'est
good qu'est ce qui te fait chier
elle n'a pas une soeur non bah c'est
dommage
elle a deux frères deux fois la fetwa
suisse et près de france tu t'en fou
quoi bein c'est les techniciens sont eux
qui sont toujours pas couché le
réalisateur la scripte l' instant d'un
disque est folle de moi un core tier les
frimousses - quoi toute la troupe appuis
je crois que le frère du roi qui fait
quoi à les deux frères je vois là bon
alors dit d'accord on est d'accord on
n'en parle plus alors allé à sucer par
le frangin et [ __ ] ta gonzesse
d'accord allez salut une bonne bourre à
estomper
[Musique]
ouais oui c'est qu'ils jérolas aux rats
comment ça va mon maître à penser ça m'a
fait rire mais bon bon bien sûr ce que
regardent pas parce que l'on imagine
bien que chose à faire mais j'ai un
certain nombre d'amis qui te regarde
ouais et qui sont unanimes et oublie
fait infligeant à la maison pour me dire
où il en est on a mis à faire une
émission tout seul comme ça strictement
avec les moyens qui tape déjà de plus
d'un siècle
c'est quoi ben ouais c'est hugo obligé
lancé on s'est réfugié dans un dans une
espèce de cinéma désaffecté travaux sont
même pas fini personne n'est payé tout
le monde fume des pétards et boit du
champagne
enfin si tu veux c'est vraiment je crois
que c'est la fin de la télévision là où
là je crois que ça y est la khl actuelle
en tout cas
professionnels de moins stressé pour moi
c'est un une forme de suicide toi tu
vois balas tous grades monde fou et
d'habitude quand on a un ami qui touche
un peu le fond jeudi bafa la maison à
l'occasion mais voilà au moins autant
mais je peux même plusieurs fois je
préfère pas que tu parles c'est à cause
des ghosts at-on dit tim bois bas après
franchement pour eux voir une épave
s'est pas fait par une chose tu as peur
que tu as faim alors c'est intégré sais
que je peux refaire un succès tu me
connais je sais que je peux remonter
tu peux toujours rebondir attendu
connaît tous et que j'y suis déjà arrivé
plusieurs fois remontant très confiant à
y croire du tout sinon je suis jamais
remonté au point où j'étais avant de
tomber en même temps c'est un peu moins
que la fois d'avant je la passe et
comment ça finit quoi c'est au bout de
la piste est encore plus bloc bloc et
puis on a beau tirer sur les doigts par
armand le c'est vrai je suis un peu
comme un élastique vieille élastique tu
vois ce que je veux dire toute la nuit
si si si si si si si si avec d'accord
mais j'ai plus que ça maintenant après
la vendée confère à pau par les actes
kraft comme une merde quoi là steven
hayes les standardistes motive n'y en a
qu'une qui m'aiment
c'est la standard nice est en train de
manger mais tu es petites taches
blanches sur la jambe
d'accord c'est pas du tout ce que tu
crois on n'en est plus là je t'embrasse
françois merci de m'avoir à jouer en
tous les cas la main poule
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu